[Music]
thank you
welcome once again to another episode of
what's a Prof
well Martin we're continuing our little
discussion I'm sure the people who were
anxious to see what's happening next I
hope so uh I am so let's open with a
word of praying and get it right into it
hi heavenly father it's a privilege to
study your creation
we can just stand in awe at everything
that you've given us to acknowledge that
you truly exist help us to realize this
and help us in this discussion and also
viewers and listeners in Jesus name amen
amen
well Martin last time we spoke about
how all of this came into existence now
all of this beauty that you see
and the ability to see it in the first
place with all the intricacy that's
involved with that
was an explosion from nothing well you
mentioning this just take the eye
there's not even a camera
on Earth that can replicate an eye
you're right with focusing and the
different colors I mean you have to have
so many settings just to if you take
your camera from here to there then you
have to adjust everything and go crazy
your eye does it automatically and the
depths I mean mine are getting old now I
need a little bit of assistance but
it'll go back to the original it's okay
you started off with good eyes and when
you were a kid so we're talking about in
the beginning part two now
and we were lost with the big bang and
we had discussed what science says about
the Big Bang
so in our last discussion we discussed
how science claims that everything we
have in the universe came about by an
explosion of nothing nothing now we were
discussing
10 questions
now the ninth one is the evolution of
the molecules of life because they all
require totally different environmental
conditions
to come into existence without enzymes
and some have never been produced under
any simulated environmental conditions
then why do we cling to this explanation
for the origins of the chemical of life
the Big Bang produced all the elements
so they say
now these elements are basically the
periodic table Yeah okay everything
that's in them and one of them is carbon
of course and life is based on carbon
hydrogen oxygen how did you combine
those into the molecules that are
required for life that requires a
different kind of evolution
and it has to come about
naturalistically because remember
there's no God
there is no organizer
we haven't even looked at some of the
other questions that we had like
irreducible complexity and all of those
issues we'll come to that just now
so how did these chemicals that you need
for Life come into existence in the
first place right because all you had
was an explosion of nothing
to produce to produce everything but in
order to produce everything everything
had to coalesce back on itself explode
again after multiplying itself in
nuclear fusions create the elements for
the evolution of molecules so that you
eventually can have life it's a very big
issue
so moreover the reactions that have been
simulated produce left and right-handed
molecules
but life can only use the left-handed
glycemic molecules and there's no random
mechanism that allows for this
moreover the early atmosphere would have
to have been a reducing atmosphere
devoid of oxygen
but if water is essential for evolution
of life then the absence of an ozone
layer without oxygen
then you would have had Cosmic radiation
would split the water into a hydrogen
and oxygen radicals and the atmosphere
could never have been a reducing
atmosphere now that's a mouthful shall
we unpack it please
okay let's have a look at this
how do we get organic molecules you have
to get it naturalistically now this was
the famous experiment by Stanley Miller
where he postulated a soup
with elements in it
and an atmosphere but he had a closed
system can you see it's totally closed
everything is closed off and then he had
an atmosphere which contained methane
ammonia
and hydrogen
so there's a nitrogen in there there's a
carbon in there there's a hydrogen in
there but there's no Oxygen can you see
that yes
so that's a reducing atmosphere
because if you put oxygen in there
nothing will happen because the moment
you create something it will oxidize and
be gone it'll burn up
so you can never get molecules
naturalistically if you have an
atmosphere that has oxygen in it but in
order to have something happen you have
to have something to dissolve in it in
and that's water
and water as oxygen and water consists
of hydrogen and oxygen
so now you have a misnomer
so you have this atmosphere it has no
oxygen but you have water
now if there is no oxygen in our
atmosphere
then under the current model
there would also be no ozone layer
because that consists of oxygen
and under the current model yeah
the ozone layer is what protects this
Earth from cosmic radiation
so without the oxygen
there would be massive radiation coming
in to our atmosphere yeah you're with me
yes yes now if there's water
then there will be water vapor in the
atmosphere and that consists of hydrogen
and oxygen when the cosmic radiation
strikes it it will split the oxygen off
from the hydrogen
and then you will have oxygen yeah and
you don't have a reducing atmosphere
then nothing will happen
but you see they're very clever they've
got a closed system here
so when you put Sparks through this now
which simulates the radiation and the
drama that's taking place then you get
chemical reactions
and then you can open this little Tab
and you can eventually see wow I
actually got organic molecules
so I know how life could have started
how the organic molecules could come
into existence
but the flaw is
there's no Oxygen
but you have water that's the floor yeah
all right now but that's not the only
floor
there's more to this let's have a look
so they have to assume that the
Primitive Earth had a reducing
atmosphere because as soon as you put
oxygen into the mix
everything that could possibly be
produced would be destroyed the Split
Second it is produced
so we have a pretty good idea what
happens a billionth of a billionth of a
second after something is produced uh
let's just put that in there because
that's what they said last time
so they postulate that the Primitive
Earth consisted or the atmosphere
consisted of hydrogen ammonia carbon
dioxide methane nitrogen and water okay
but now they've got the problem again
you have a problem because then you
would have radiation and that would
split this into hydrogen and oxygen
radicals and you would have an oxidizing
atmosphere but uh
just for the sake of getting rid of God
let's assume that the water stayed water
now where does this atmosphere come from
well you have to postulate that it came
from volcanic activity so the Earth was
a bubbling cauldron of heated magma with
lots of gases being produced
and Volcanic gases consist of carbon
dioxide
sulfur dioxide hydrochloric acid
nitrogen and water I'm afraid now you
have an oxidizing atmosphere
so you cannot use that atmosphere you
have to have this one
all right so that one the Primitive
Earth one can only
according to them
must come about by the volcanic cases
but that's not possible that's not going
to happen so you have a little bit of a
problem here so you have to
automatically postulate that in the past
the gases that were produced are
different to what they are now that's
contrary to the uniformitarian principle
which says everything in the past must
be able to be explained by things in the
present okay
our present atmosphere is totally
useless for this because it contains
carbon dioxide oxygen that's a
dead in the water
nitrogen water and then a number of
inert gases so this is totally different
as well so there's a problem at that
level right
okay so if you do this experiment and
you actually combine some of these
molecules then you can get primitive
molecules to form
like amino acids for example yeah okay
all right now let's have a look at the
amino acids
these are two forms of amino acids we
call them racemic mixtures you get L
amino acids
and you get D amino acids
that's like your left and your right
hand which are mirror images of each
other yeah
okay your right hand doesn't look like
your left hand otherwise your thumb
would be on that side right so they're
mirror images
so just like you have two hands that are
mirror images these amino acids or
mirror images of each other can you see
that yes I see okay this one is an L
amino acid which is the left-handed
amino acid and this one is a
right-handed amino acid you with me
exactly okay I understand now life only
uses El amino acids
but if you have this production of amino
acids then you have a little problem
because you produce left and
right-handed amino acids okay so you
have a mixture now of left and
right-handed ones but somehow because
life only uses the left-handed ones you
must have a mechanism of selecting only
the left-handed ones and for that you
need an enzyme but the enzyme consists
of them so how do you get the enzyme to
only take the left to actually be
produced with only left-handed ones by
chance yeah
can you see you have a major problem
here huge it's easy to say okay I've got
a mixture of protein-like substances but
they're useless for life exactly so
there's another problem yeah
an amino acid has this group over here
this carboxyl group over here cooh
and the first carbon that's what makes
it an acid okay the first carbon after
this group is called the alpha carbon
okay it's the first carbon and then you
have many many carbons that you can put
in a row after that that will be the
better the Delta the gamma etc etc amino
acids so this amino group over here
which makes it an amino acid
always is attached to the alpha carbon
but there's no reason why it can't be
attached to the beep beta or any of the
subsequent carbons so what makes it
juice okay first one so if you get this
random mixture you will get left-handed
amino acids you will get right-handed
amino acids you'll get Alpha Beta Delta
gamma any of that gamut but life only
uses
l
Alpha
what mechanism must there be to select
them out of this pool
because if you make a protein and there
happens to be one that is not alpha or
one that is not L it's useless yeah it
doesn't work
mutton there is a design feature there
and there is no designer because there
is no God how do you get it
so they get this pot of boiling things
and there are protein Nations molecules
in there and they're very excited and
foxes protein the scientist Fox had
these bowls of proteinaceous substances
totally useless for life but very
exciting because you've got a protein
substance
can you see there's no sulfur in there
no
and in the atmosphere they also didn't
have any sulfur
but some amino acids contain sulfur so
you have to somehow add that later
because you also need sulfur containing
amino acids so it's a major problem
you might be able to get the
protein-like substance but but it's
useless yes without the mechanism
to extract it the mechanism is in the
enzyme and yeah and an enzyme consists
of amino acids which have come together
as a protein
it only has L and Alpha nothing else so
how did it get it because it would never
get it naturalistically now something
has to physically choose it yes but
there is nothing to choose exactly
according to them and you can't use an
enzyme because they don't exist yet
and by the way if you want to get really
complicated the enzymes sequence and
structures coded for by the DNA
and the DNA consists of these
nitrogenous bases adenine guanine
thymine cytosine and RNA contains uracil
as well
now you can see that this is a totally
different structure right
now the atmosphere
that you had to produce the amino acids
doesn't produce these okay so now you
need another atmosphere
so now you create another atmosphere are
you going to create another atmosphere
if you have a closed system and this
Earth is the closed system you have to
somehow postulate that it happened
somewhere else right so now it didn't
happen here on Earth
that's right so you have to develop
another theory and say well maybe it
couldn't have happened on Earth so they
have another theory which is called pan
spermia it came from outer space okay so
meteors had the circumstances that were
required and these molecules were flown
in and happened to be put into the
mixture that was bubbling down here and
that's how we got these things
Martin are you in the realm of science
or are you in the realm of faith
indefinitely in the Ralph and realm of
Faith all right and like because now
you've got space
involved and everything differently it's
like you mentioned that other mysticism
is almost Incorporated here at this all
right now remember everything has mirror
images as well you cannot use the Murray
images
now I'm not even going to go into the
sugars because sugars we only use the D
sugar
you cannot use the others and you also
need a totally different circumstance
and different molecular environment in
order to get them so how are you going
to get all that it is so complex and
without enzymes nothing works and some
of these have never been produced no
matter what environmental condition you
simulated okay
so you have to postulate that we just
haven't discovered it yet
so that's why they probably is this the
reason they start at CERN
well that's to find out the particles
that they ex to find out what the
particles consist of and what energy
there is and whether there is a quantum
leap that you have to take and maybe
even a wormhole or it we're now in the
realm of Science Fiction
mingled with science and we could blow
ourselves all up in the process but be
that as of now let's stick to the
chemicals bottom line is
in order for life to evolve you need all
the chemicals
so in the textbooks they just glibly
give you these experiments and say here
they are
but they don't say that they're totally
useless nor do they say how are they
ordered how do you get from this chaos
to this order
because it's against the law of
thermodynamics to go from the chaos to
the order you go from the order to the
chaos so it's not as cut and dried no as
they would have you believe
and then we also posed the question
if life suddenly appeared on this Earth
in another explosion
um
and all of the sudden all the animals
were there
in the Cambrian the oldest fossil
bearing macro fossil layers
suddenly all the phyla were there
that's when life exploded
now this is what science has to teach
this is punctuated equilibrium at its
best this is an article that appeared in
Scientific American and it says evidence
obtained by sequencing the 18s ribosomal
RNA molecules
that Aid in the synthesis of proteins
from various species
suggests that many of the phyla remember
we said that's the large category of oh
yes yes
appeared almost simultaneously
Martin
evolutionary speaking isn't that
ridiculous that's 100 contrary to what
evolution is teaching you now God said
he spoke and there they were
what is evolution saying exactly the
same exactly the same so you have a
choice between two options one
eliminating God one incorporating God
I admit I don't know where God comes
from no I admit it too but he says I am
that's it they say they are too because
their God is nothing that exploded and
created everything so where did the
nothing come from that created
everything it just is yes so God says he
is there nothing is
okay
so how fast did Evolution take place
other discoveries continued to highlight
the speed and magnitude of the Cambrian
explosion
bowring and Collings recently provided
our first rigorous radiometric dates for
the event and fast turns out to be much
faster than anyone ever thought in fact
they call it evolving at supersonic
speed
so fast that you cannot find any
intermediary fossils because they're all
there at the same time
isn't that the same as creation it's
exactly the same why do you want to put
millions of years to it then
and then a little honest admission
all the textbooks Proclaim that our
phylum
the Cordata did not appear until the
subsequent or the vegan period
and that this later Evolution must imply
Advanced status
but the burgers Shale which is
Cambrian
contains a chordate oops so the group
that we belong to was there from the
beginning
yeah
Jen and colleagues Discovery and
description of a beautifully preserved
and unambiguously identified call
chordate from the still earlier Cheng
Yang fauna now seals the fate of this
misguided effort
in asserting specialness for our
ancestry chordates arose in the Cambrian
explosion period
it was all there from the beginning
do they put this in textbooks as well no
no
so let's unpack this Martin here you
have what you will find in textbooks
they're called
evolutionary trees
and you have for example if you take the
reptiles you have the amphibian
and the amphibian gave rise to the
pleasure SARS and gave rise to all of
these and then the dinosaurs and all the
various ones Triceratops over there and
the flying reptiles and of course
Tyrannosaurus and all of them can you
see how they evolve and then out of them
we have the modern reptiles you see that
okay
now Martin
there's the amphibian
and let's take it there and go all the
way up over here
to the turtle and the Tortoise
they split somewhere over there is there
any fossil that they've put on the line
here no no
because this tortoise and this turtle
has been a tortoise and a turtle from
the beginning so in actual fact there is
no tree is there any fossil here that
they put there no no
so where does this come from faith it
comes out of the mind of the scientists
so he finds these in the Rocks they're
all in the same level
and now he puts them together to decide
and tell you how they came into
existence right so this is just like you
said it's out of his mind this is a
chart that somebody drew because he
thinks this is the only logic
explanation correct so this is called an
evolutionary tree
when in actual fact because they're all
there at the same time it's actually an
evolutionary lawn yeah because you can
take this line all the way down to the
beginning
and that one all the way down to the
beginning and that one all the way down
to the beginning in fact they call this
a living fossil
because it's never changed except for
its size it went from large to small so
okay so it actually devolves it went
from large to small yes it deteriorated
the Bible says the Earth is wearing out
like a garment it's deteriorating and
everything on it is deteriorating with
it if you take just the ages of man
there used to be 900 and something years
old and today if you're lucky you get to
80 right
so there's a deterioration and you go
from giant people to small people the
entire fossil record does that that's in
harmony with scripture exactly
and if you go to the serpent or any one
of these creatures they all go down as
straight lines like grass in a lawn
and there is no common ancestor
so this is pure conjecture you know I
remember the silicant
it was extinct and I think in in South
Africa on the shore of death found that
that's it and that fish is about
supposed to be 320 million or something
odd years correct but it hasn't changed
anything from them no because it was the
fish from the beginning the same applies
to the sturgeon
which has uh scales on its back and
therefore bony scales and therefore it's
primitive but in actual fact the Bony
scale is more advanced than a normal
scale so it's totally topsy-turvy
all right let me explain how this comes
into being now here's an evolutionary
tree that I could postulate
considering that Evolution would have to
go from small to large if we want to
categorize the dog species let's start
with a Chihuahua that's a small dog
and then it has to get larger over time
although the fossil record shows the
reverse right yeah
so here we have the little Chihuahua and
it looks like that and here on this side
you have the flat nosed dog species you
know there yeah so they must have
evolved over here
and the longer nosed ones or the ones
let's say with floppy ears over here
must be on a different line
because you can see that this one has
floppy ears and that one has the longest
floppy ears so that one
is also shortened and stocky and then
you have the longer nosed ones they must
have evolved more or less like that that
sounds perfectly logical
but it's absolute nonsense yeah
because they all evolved out of the Wolf
so the wolf at all of this genetic
capacity within it
it's like the horse
is there evolutionary tree so they start
off with the hierarch ethereum over
there because it looked like a rock
hyrax
and they put them into sequence like
this and then you get the modern horse
and they show how the the legs changed
and how they came into
existence now this is a German slide but
that's fine
so Martin the interesting thing is that
this is again pure conjecture because
all of these creatures occur at the same
time just like the dogs
so when you take the entire variety over
here and I want to say how it evolved
I would take the smallest one and put it
in line This is natural variation
that is built in
natural variation exactly I can put it
into a secret but it comes out of the
Mind mind because yeah it it's not
necessarily that all right now human
beings
do they have for example face
recognition yes all right so that means
that faces must be different yes so
would you assume that God is a lover of
variety oh definitely all right how does
science account for the variety that is
in the gene pool
they have to postulate that all of these
wonderful mechanisms that create variety
came into existence by chance
but they're so intricate as we will see
in a moment that the smack of design
yeah
but you cannot postulate the designer so
we have a problem we have a problem
let's take the evolution of man
oh they are so sure that we all evolved
from Australopithecus
means ape
so Martin they have these evolutionary
trees and they give you the evolution of
man out of this evolutionary tree and
then out of one of them finally they get
to the hominids that look like modern
man and that's the evolution and here we
have it from the Primitive to the modern
and they postulate this as an
evolutionary tree again it's not true
it's a lawn all in the same time all of
them were there at the same time
so all the monkeys that we have
and the human beings that we have with
all the variety we're there from the
beginning beginning
so that variety
for all the Apes must have been in the
ape species the variety for Humanity the
various shapes and sizes and forms must
be in the original gene pool of one pair
with the capacity
to get the variety so how do we get the
capacity how do we get the variety
remember we spoke about genotype and
phenotype and the last one and we
explained what that was
so the genotype is all the genes in an
organism
and the phenotype are all the visible
traits that are expressed by the genes
so I explained that last time remember
these are this is your phenotype this is
your genotype yes
now
I won't know what is written in this
book
until I read it yeah until you open it
yeah okay so natural selection can do
nothing with my book
natural selection cannot improve it
natural legs and cannot say I'm going to
improve this book without looking inside
it takes an intelligent somebody to read
the book and to see
what's in it right
so natural selection doesn't work at
this level
so let's try and unpack that a little
bit
so the book is your genotype and the
result thereof is the phenotype so if
the book for example contains the
building plan for building an airplane
this one yeah
and that is the phenotype the actual
airplane that is produced there's a
there's a few things that must happen
between the book
and the airplane
right quite a few things quite a few
things number one
somebody must write the book yes okay
yeah but there's no God no
no so it must be chance so God never
wrote the book chance wrote the book
that's a assumption in The evolutionary
theory
okay
Chancellor at the book
now if I have the book I don't have an
airplane I just have a book you just
have the information and I don't even
know if it flies exactly how must I know
when it flies I must build it after the
you can only use the phenotype to see if
it fires
you're getting this right yeah do you
find this discussion interesting very
because now the genes is also just still
stuff that has to be put together
two we already discussed how it came
about
how you get the molecules to create the
book
and let alone you're not talking about
anybody who wrote the book you just have
the book
and the book is the blueprint for that
now if you want to create the airplane
well Martin is it enough to have the
book no you have to have material you
have to have the material that is
described in the book and then and then
you must have an engineer somebody to
put it together exactly now if I Martin
as you are now gave you all the material
to put something together or let's say I
gave you the metal yeah and I said you
have to create the cogs and the wheels
and everything to create the engine and
the Wings Etc wouldn't you have to have
a factory definitely wouldn't you have
to have equipment in order to build it
without that equipment with the airplane
appear no
so we're going to get the equipment from
you only have a book
you have to gather it all right the
point is that I'm making
it's not enough Martin to have the book
exactly you have to have all the
equipment plus the engineers
plus the people building it in between
before you can actually
have the airplane yeah
so I haven't put anything in between
here but everything in between the book
and the airplane
where does it come from well according
to them probably then chance
absolutely right because it's not
subject to Natural Selection until the
airplane is there and you can see
whether it flies are you with me yeah
so it's not enough to say I have created
the building blocks over here
in order to write the book I have
written the book without the designer
without a writer I have created the
factory
and I have eventually a product and now
I can see if it flies
but for natural selection to work
selection implies more than one
I cannot choose between options if there
isn't more than one that's it so it
doesn't only have to happen once it has
to happen
millions of times and you have to have
something that can produce this the
following so there must be of male
female so how much Faith do you need
all right
so is it true then that selection
requires that more than one variant
exists yeah
so we need all of these different
blueprints we need different books
different genetic codes it's just
handwriting telling you what to do we
have to have the equipment to actually
do it
and then we have to have a product to
test
and there's no God there's no designer
yeah so that's out and everything that
happens until the product actually
appears happens by chance
now let's just unpack that Martin
our book
this one is a very special book this one
because it gives you the Plan of
Salvation it's actually got who is the
chance in there the chance designer is
in here as well yes right there from the
beginning nobody wants to know that so
we'll put the book down
now what is written in the blueprint
so that you can become you
that must be right because originally
you started off as a little cell half
the information from your father half
the information from your mother that
was mixed together miraculously to
become one
then it actually unpacked the
information and used a factory that was
all in there yeah somebody put the
factory in there because it's no good
having the information without the
factory because you have to produce the
thing so in that cell was the
information plus there was a factory
and the factory
just did what the instructions told them
without any designer whatsoever
and your information was in the DNA
and your factory was in the rest of the
cell
so you had to get the information from
the DNA
and transcribe it so that you could take
it out of the cell to your factory
and then that transcription was called
mRNA
which was a copy of what the information
said in the DNA but it was actually a
mirror copy okay so the mirror copy is
the information of what actually has to
happen and what is in the DNA is the
reverse of what has to happen so it's
quite a tricky little thing chance is a
very good designer
and then it had to go and it had to find
a factory and fortunately there was a
factory
the information as to how the factory
came about was actually in there in the
first place because without it there
would be no Factory this is really
fascinating and then once the
information was slotted in the photocopy
was put into this thing called the
ribosome and then it was changed or the
information was read and produced a
protein
choosing only L Alpha amino acids
ignoring anything else that was in the
original soup very clever little machine
and I think we should have a little look
at what this actually looks like in an
animated little sequence
that is very well done
with computer animation we can enter the
cell to view this remarkable system at
work
thank you after entering the heart of
the cell we see that tightly wound
strands of DNA storehouses for the
instructions necessary to build every
protein in an organism
[Music]
in a process known as transcription a
molecular machine first unwinds a
section of the DNA Helix to expose the
genetic instructions needed to assemble
a specific protein molecule
another machine then copies these
instructions to form a molecule known as
messenger RNA
foreign
[Music]
is complete the Slender RNA strand
carries the genetic information through
the nuclear pore complex
the gatekeeper for traffic in and out of
the cell nucleus
the messenger RNA strand is directed to
a two-part molecular Factory called a
ribosome
after attaching itself securely the
process of translation begins
[Music]
inside the ribosome a molecular assembly
line builds a specifically sequenced
chain of amino acids these amino acids
are transported from other parts of the
cell and then linked into chains often
hundreds of units long
their sequential Arrangement determines
the type of protein manufactured
foreign
[Music]
is finished it is moved from the
ribosome to a barrel-shaped machine that
helps fold it into the precise shape
critical to its function
[Music]
thank you
after the chain is folded into a protein
it is then released and shepherded by
another molecular machine to the exact
location where it is needed
modern I have just produced one little
sub component of what you're going to
make right yeah and and all of this is
not subject to Natural Selection only
the final product the airplane yeah is
going to be subject it all came about by
chance
how much fast do you need well you need
a tremendous amount of faith if you want
to say this is by chance this is by
chance absolutely all right
so Martin you have thousands of genes
and you create thousands of different
kinds of cells you don't just consist of
one kind of cell that's another major
problem in itself
how do you know which genes to activate
and which not to activate
and sometimes there are alleles in other
words copies of certain informations
each one with a different variant of the
same thing so that you can get different
varieties yeah and if you mingle two
sixes together now you get that Variety
in there and you produce all of this
variety but it comes about by chance
so you must have mechanisms not only to
read that DNA
you must have controlling genes which
say which ones must be read
and then you must have
activators that bind to certain it's
like switching on a light switch yes
but you have to have someone to switch
it on exactly and you must have a switch
yeah and if you have two lights then you
must have two switches to switch on one
and the other one off and the other one
on and the other one off you know what I
mean exactly where all those things come
from
it's like that video now
all this
DNA and everything yeah that's fine but
then you have a machine where did the
machine come from where did that come
from it has to come about by chance
and then you have transpositions
so a transposon is a piece of dni that
can be cut out precisely sliced out of a
piece of DNA and sliced in somewhere
else
but it has to be a very precise process
because modern if you just Skip One
of those messages then your whole
message is destroyed because you're one
out of sequence granted everything is
corrupted it's like taking a letter out
of a word everything moves up and
nothing makes sense anymore
so all of these mechanisms are very very
precise they may not have a built-in
error or else you get gibberish at the
end
how did it come about
chance
so you can go from a small rat to a
giant rat
with one Activity one translocating of a
gene to another position
where let's say the the the gene for
growth hormone yeah is read more often
in that position than in this position
then you will have a larger Mouse as a
result so you can adapt to
environmental changes and become larger
or smaller
considering the environment but the
mechanism is complex and very precise
but there's no designer
and there's no evolution
and then let's not even talk about
epigenetics
I don't want to go into too much a
detail but epigenetics is a way of even
transferring
character trays
behavior from one generation to another
you know in the past we thought the only
thing that is transferred from one
generation to another is the physical
hardcore information as to what you are
but no through epigenetics which we're
not going to run into detail they can
look at the other lectures for that
epigenetics makes it possible for
behaviors
if you're inclined to anger if you're
inclined to whatever so it's also that's
also on the gene type there's genes that
actually activated yes to give that
Trend and it's interesting that if you
stop at particular behavior that is
let's say a detrimental Behavior it can
take two three four generations to get
rid of it so you can inherit bad
character traits from your parents it
doesn't mean you have to listen to them
you have to change them if you are
inclined to anger and violence and you
inherit this through epigenetics
now the Bible says to the third and
fourth generation you will have to
struggle with some of these things
and it's so in harmony with with science
but this complicated mechanism
where certain genes are active and some
are actually suppressed so for example
Martin if you have a propensity in the
family
to get breast cancer
and you know that the stimulus for
breast cancer is eating particular foods
like fried foods etc etc
if you cut it out and you no longer do
that even though you have the propensity
you can actually put it to rest yeah
with this kind of activity and if you do
the wrong thing then it can be activated
again so it's a complicated mechanism
which we're not going to discuss for the
purposes but the interesting fact is
that the variety that we have in the
world
is a built-in variety
very coordinated very precise
and it's all in the genes and not
subject to natural selection
now let's have a look at another point
to ponder and that is irreducible
complexity
that is when I explained to you that
certain things need to have all the
components like a watch yeah otherwise
otherwise it's not going to work you
take out one it doesn't work
so I cannot get this watch to produce
Itself incrementally by itself
I would one day have to just pick up a
watch
biologically speaking yes oh here's a
how did it come into existence it's
irreducibly complex
so let's have a look at something that
is irreducibly complex we're not going
to go into the details of the science
because this is not supposed to be a
hardcore yeah yeah science lecture we're
talking about the philosophy the
principle behind it but just for
interest sake
uh here is an article in a peer-reviewed
journal structure and function of the
bi-directional bacterial flagella motor
oh
now
an organism a unicellular organism can
have a little tail-like structure which
is the flagellum which rotates and
makes the organism move
and Martin you produce millions of them
it's called the sperm cell and it has a
little flagella motor and it makes it
possible for it to swim and create a
fusion with a female germ cell and
produce the next Offspring now that
little motor just that little motor
it cannot come about incrementally
everything has to be there okay
otherwise it doesn't work so let's just
read this not for the sake of unpacking
it just to give you an idea
here's the abstract the bacterial
flagellum is a locomotive organelle that
propels the bacterial cell body in
liquid environments the flagellum is a
supramolecular complex composed of about
30 different proteins and consists of at
least three parts a rotary motor a
universal joint and a helical filament
the flagellum motor of E coli and
salmonella Etc powered by an inward
directed electrochemical potential
difference of protons across the
cytoplasmic membrane it needs fuel yeah
just like any motor
the flagella motor consists of a rotor
made of all of these different proteins
and a dozen status consisting of this
that this this this this that also act
as a molecular switch
enabling the motor to spin in both
counterclockwise and clockwise
directions so it's got a forward gear
and a backward gear
each SATA is anchored to the peptoglycan
layer through AC terminal periplasmic
domain of such and such acts as a
protein channel to couple the protein
flow through the Channel with torque
generation you're gonna talk generator
okay it is a highly sophisticated motor
that consists of all these components
you take out one it doesn't work what's
it look like it looks like this if
so here it is and there are the
components that's what it looks like
these are all the different protein
rings that it has and it can move
forward and it can move backward and it
has torque and it can go over obstacles
it can go slow it can go fast it is a
magnificent motor
but it has to be complete
or it doesn't work what
how to come into existence chance
all right you want to unpack it a little
bit more
schematic diagram of the bacterial
proton driven and
sodium driven flagella motor
and these are so efficient
they're better than any diesel motor or
anything that has ever been designed by
humanity and there they go this is what
they consist of you take out one little
component it's broken
it doesn't work
I don't come into existence it's
irreducibly complex
let's take a chloroplast
this is the PowerHouse of our planet in
terms of life this is what creates
energy out of the atmosphere yeah
this is what uses sunlight in order to
create molecules so that you can stay
alive right it produces energy in the
form of carbohydrates and it consists of
this structure so it's a photo system
two electron transport chain photo
system that captures light and together
with water and oxygen in This
Magnificent reaction that takes place
over here produces starch amino acids
fatty acids but it exports sucrose
so there it is and it is a
magnificent structure you take out any
part of it it doesn't work and life is
dependent upon it
mutton
it just suddenly appeared one day
it gets better and better I mean
I
you start to really think that these
people that Proclaim to be so clever in
putting this all to chance uh really how
but they don't say that
they pack it in scientific jargon so
that it looks so feasible leaving out
the problems that are associated with
that's the thing if you just go back to
that picture that you showed about the
drawing and that just comes out of a
guy's mind they don't tell you that no
they don't tell you this they tell you
what it looks like they're over awed at
the complexity and the beauty of it
I mean you give it oxygen you give it
water
and you give it carbon and here comes
product that you need for life it's just
amazing but it's a very intricate
machine yeah
now when you go to the fossil record and
you look at insects for example they've
always been insects
everything about it and how it came into
existence comes out of the mind of the
scientists it's like taking the
Chihuahua to the Great Dane and packing
it in a sequence and say that's how it
happened
but they were all there at the same time
so an insect in the fossil record looks
like this and it will look like this to
this day except that it might be smaller
now here's a very interesting
development
here you have a dragonfly you get
dragonflies with one wings and you get
dragonflies with two Wings right
now you get helicopters with one rotor
and helicopters with two rotors did you
know that the helicopter was designed
with the dragonfly in mind I heard that
okay so the engineers looked at the
dragonfly
but now you have a problem because the
dragonfly has a fixed wing
but Beatles for example have a wing that
falls away and is hidden under carapace
to protect it like a hard cover it's
like taking it to a garage but you have
to fold it up
how do you get from a fixed Wing which
looks like more primitive so say the
dragonfly is more primitive than the
beetle because the beetle can fold its
wings and put it into a carapace there's
no intermediary you just have the two
and now you have to postulate out the
one came out of the other and you assume
that this one must have been first
because this one over here where you
actually fold it away is more complex
actually you actually think it's more
complex but they use this one to design
the helicopters
what will happen if we use Beetle wings
to produce something okay so according
to them there's no evidence that they
ever evolved or if you take the eye
it consists this is now compound eye of
an insect right
it has a very complex structure of
mirrors
and those mirrors are omitidia they are
all packed in and they make a composite
picture and out of that composite
picture the brain
has to make one picture
it is so complicated and it's
irreducibly complex because you take
away a component it doesn't work
besides that you need an interpretative
computer
to take the actual electronic image and
change it into a virtual image right
yeah where the computer come from who
designed all of this stuff now here is
an an insect in Amber this is a fossil
so the first time an eye appears in the
fossil record it is fully formed like a
modern one
because you cannot reduce it to
something less yes because then it
wouldn't work it doesn't work
irreducible complexity and they've
always been there from the same time
ants in Amber no wonder they can make a
joke I can't believe it Fred 60 million
years since I seen you lost and you
haven't changed the bet
because there is no fossil to show how
this one even evolved because it's the
same as the one that lives today 100 the
same except for size
so we spoke about variation and we said
that modification in the genes in your
genotype to bring about changes in the
phenotype occur by chance through
mutation this all happens by chance
natural selection has nothing to do with
it only once it's produced
can selection say this one doesn't work
that one let's choose that one right
and genetic recombination is produced by
fertilization
meiosis
as independent assortment and crossing
over that's to produce variety now this
is the process
the one is the male the other one is the
female
in order to get the variety where they
come from
no chance because the variety is
produced by the combining of the male
and the female
but the all that it entails to be a male
and all that it entails to be a female
must be there before you can get the
variety
Chicken and the Egg
all right so now here are your
chromosomes
and one of them is from your father and
one of them is from your mother
right
now they're going to divide
and split into components and then
they're going to exchange information
and that looks then like that
so the red is from your father
and the blue let's say is from your
mother
and they're going to exchange
information so then in the end of the
process you have a little bit of blue
you have a little bit of red you have a
little bit of blue and you have a little
bit of red and this process is called
crossing over
it is incredibly complex one little
mistake yeah and you're a cabbage
Martin this does nothing other than
increase the variety in The Offspring
but natural selection can only determine
whether that variety is useful once it's
there so this whole process is chance
came about by chance yeah
it is so complicated
because it has to be at the precise
Locus so you have to have an enzyme that
cuts
your father's DNA at the right place and
cuts your mother's DNA at the right
place then splices them together so that
the same information is there just in a
different variety of form yeah and
exactly the same place because if it's
in the wrong one little bit a billionth
of a billion per second off
you've had it nothing happens so Martin
this complex mechanism
that produces more variety in The
Offspring
is a complicated system that is so
mind-boggling that if you go into all
the detail as to how it happens and what
enzymes are involved and how the
replicating enzymes have to work and how
you have editing enzymes running
afterwards to make sure there's no
mistake because I don't want you to be a
cabbage whoever designed it doesn't want
you to be a cabbage
yeah
but there's no designer
there's no designer so this is how it
works can you see yeah so you cross them
over and then eventually you have a
little bit of one and a little bit of
the other but you have this thousands of
times
it's an amazing process okay
so let us just recap then do you need a
lot of faith to assume that the
mechanisms
that produce the variation the male and
the female aspect the whole system to
create the variation by crossing over
the genes creating all of those
possibilities in an absolutely
controlled precise manner came about by
chance
absolutely crazy faith all right
but you have to have crazy Faith to
believe in God as well that's it so you
have a scale you have
you have a scale you can put it on the
scale and you can determine for yourself
what you want to believe
what if you add prophecy to the mix no
no then you're gonna have what if that
Designer says to you excuse me
you don't want to believe it's me you
want to believe it's somebody called
charts let me tell you what's going to
happen in
one thousand years yeah
at exactly this time
at exactly this place
exactly out of this lineage this person
is going to be born and he's going to do
this this this this this this this this
and the other
and as far as the kingdoms of the world
are concerned let me explain to you that
when this Kingdom that now rules is gone
that one's going to take over and then
in 600 years that one will take over and
in 300 years that one will take over and
then that one and then when that happens
they're going to divide into so many and
that one will be a ruler and this one
will do this and this and this and this
and this and then it happens
will they have proved that he has
knowledge that is inexplicable beyond
the doubt can you put that on the scale
as well on the which scale now on the
scale of the is a God yes but you can
you put it on the other side no not
because it doesn't exist as a nightmare
okay all right
all right let's just wrap this up and
talk about a few other things
the Bible says there was a universal
flood and the universal destruction
right
now geologists divide the sequences of
the Rocks into what they call a
geological column right
and the oldest Strata with the macro
fossils down there is the Cambrian
and that's where macro Evolution or the
origin of larger animals actually
started to occur and logically
they should start developing as you go
up over here so you shouldn't find you
should find very primitive ones down
here and then the more advanced ones as
you go up right but as we saw they all
occur over there at the same time
Cambrian explosion that's the first
problem
the next problem that you have is as you
go up over here
you come to the quaternary up there and
that's where they say where we have
the mammals and the intelligent beings
that we have over here but before you
get there you have a layer here which is
called the Cretaceous
now Cretaceous means chalk
okay that's what it looks like it's a
chalk layer
okay now can you see that you're going
up over here this is in German over here
and there's the Cretaceous layer yeah
just before you get yeah man and
everything that's living today
there's a chalk layer
and Martin that Chuck layer is universal
right over the whole earth over the
whole Earth
and what does it consist of
it consists of the calcium carbonate
bodies of organisms okay particularly
marine organisms
it's a chalk layer it's if you're right
on the board with chalk you're writing
with the fossil
and it's these over here are for Raman
nifra which are small little unicellular
shells of unicellular
uh creatures but then you'll also find
this in the chalk layer all these Marine
shells add little micro organisms and
creatures like this this is all part of
the chalk and this is all the top layer
on over the Earth it's covering
everything at the same time
here for example
is a brown coal layer
it's a mass of the largest Brown Coal
Field in the world now this is called
that's not buried in the deeper layers
it's on top so it doesn't form coal it's
just partly forms coal
and mixed with it this is in Europe
in
right up against the Alps
and in that you have this layer over
here which is a chocolate okay
now that's full of marine deposits
so that's what the chalk would look like
it's full of marine organisms yeah
marine and that means everything was
underwater yeah
okay now here is a geologist and by the
way this man was an evolutionary
geologist
and he's explaining how these Brown coal
Fields came into existence of course
they postulate that it was a a forest
That Grew there
but somehow right in the middle of
Europe everything was underwater
because you have the chalk layer and
he's holding a piece of the chalk over
there and he's showing it to us you can
compress it and write with it on the
Blackboard
and if you dig in that new grid for us
this is what you dig out
so everything was underwater no matter
where you go in the world
so what right at the top here is a layer
that says the whole world was underwater
but there was no flood uh
and what is also interesting
if you go to the rest of the fossil
record now that we have
we find graveyards of animals mammal
graveyards for example
we have them all mixed together like
this here you have all kinds of
creatures like horses and rodents and
everything mixed into one so they
definitely didn't go and decide to die
at the same time there what jumbled them
together and glued them together like us
they were catastrophically laid down
this is flood history but there was no
flood Martin there was a chalk layer
come from
and where do fossil graveyards come from
and here
you have well distribution and abundance
in the north Cheryl Blanco
and you have hundreds of whales buried
instantly you see here's a while yeah
and there's another one and you know
what's interesting they're largely
stream orientated they all died in the
same direction
this is catastrophism they were buried
at the same time is this in harmony with
the universal destructive flood exactly
but there was none it was chance and by
the way today well don't fossilize no
they Beach they break up and soon they
are in a million pieces animals eat
they're just gone yeah so you can find
fragments but here whole animals were
instantly
buried and you can find that for
dinosaurs you can find them washed into
the direction of stream flown you can
find that for petrified forests washed
into the direction of Stream flow you
can find that for fishes you can find
that for anything in the entire fossil
record it speaks of catastrophe like you
said even a fish so it had to be quick a
turbidite I think you mentioned it yes I
had to cook catch that fish right in
mid-swim and it had to be cut off from
oxygen immediately or else it would just
disintegrate
so let's ask question number 10. if the
probability of any of these mechanisms
coming into existence by chance
giving their intricacy
is so infinitely small as to be
non-existent
then does not the theory of evolution
qualifies the faith rather than a
science
I think we've actually shown that it
does
the faith it's definitely a faith and
the Bible says
choose thee this day whom You Shall
Serve if you want to serve the gods that
your forefathers served on the other
side of the river
you're welcome to it
if you want to serve Gaia
the god of naturalism and nature
you're welcome to it
but if you want to serve the god of the
Bible then choose
is there enough evidence
that God can mean exactly what he says
yes especially through prophecy as well
acknowledging it
so if we read thus the heavens and the
Earth were finished and all the hosts of
them
is it in harmony with what we saw the
fossil record reveal and the intricacy
of everything definitely they the
scientists have a term for this this is
irreducible complexity okay so when he
says in the beginning God created
and then he piles evidence upon evidence
in this book
that he is involved in in the life of
this world and that is involved even
with the animal kingdom and that it says
it is groaning under the
circumstances which were produced by sin
and that the world is looking forward to
a world-created new wherein there is no
more death none of these things are we
looking at the DNA in the world today
trying to find solutions to eternal life
yes
yeah I solution Lies over here I think
they've been trying that since death
came in yes they've been trying to
find out why does the DNA deteriorate
you know what's fascinating
our DNA is deteriorating over time right
but the germ cells we produce
even at my age can produce a viable
offspring yes what keeps that so active
what is it that God has built into these
things Martin I've come to the
conclusion in my life
that given all the facts
archaeological facts historic facts
prophetic interpretations
plus the story of Origins and the flood
in the Bible
make this the most believable book
in the universe and the most Ward
against this you see and actually you
can put on top of that scientific fact
the scientific things that you've just
shown they have an explanation for the
chance for it actually that proves that
God is the greater God is the creator
in my opinion thus the heavens and the
Earth were finished
and all the host of them and this world
is soon
coming to an end when this experiment
with this thing called sin is over
and then there will be a new Earth
and a new Heaven in which dwelleth
righteousness
and there will be no more death no more
pain no more dying
and we will be face to face with that
creator that Designer
that missing component
that explains how everything came into
existence and how it is transformed into
that which we see it's bright I mean
Heavenly Father
the world is bent on removing you
from every aspect of society
and soon Humanity will realize that this
is the path of destruction and they will
fall into another trap
and follow a line of reasoning which is
contrary to the word of God
but you've given us so much evidence
that your word is trustworthy help us to
rely not on the dictates of man but on
the thus says the Lord is my prayer in
Jesus name amen amen
thank you
[Music]
foreign